blah blah blah cold-open snarky comments
spoiler warning blah the Battle of the
five armies and no I'm not gonna call it
The Hobbit you know going to see this
movie was one of the weirder experiences
of my movie-going life because I don't
think I've ever gone to the theater to
see a movie and be more certain that I
was gonna hate it than I did with this
film I tried I tried really really hard
to try and get on this thing's
wavelength cuz I knew going in that it
was not gonna be what I wanted it to be
I knew that for a fact but I did I can't
I just can't even if I set aside my
attachment to the source material just
comparing it to the Lord of the Rings
films which I don't think anyone is
gonna argue as an invalid thing to do
that still doesn't hold up as a movie
unto itself it's okay it's fine and if
you enjoyed the other Hobbit movies
desolation of Smaug actually I've got a
call that the benchmark if you like that
one you're gonna like this but if you're
like me you felt the best Hobbit movie
was the first one because it stuck the
closest to what the heart of the book
was this is not gonna turn you around
it's not my intention to get into
spoilers but you know what I'm gonna
talk about all this different stuff that
didn't work for me and I don't care
where it happened in the movie so bright
points there were a few Martin Freeman
is still great he probably gives my
favorite performance of any character in
this entire series I include Lord of the
Rings with that his Bilbo Baggins is
exactly what I always wanted to see what
I always wanted from this character
which unfortunately in the grand scheme
is to the movies detriment because he's
as I've said with previous entries he's
not the hero he's not the main character
the actions pretty good but
unfortunately as hard as they're trying
it doesn't have the impact of something
like helms deep or the Battle of
Pellinore feels because it's trying so
hard to be those same things Helms deep
was just epic in a way that most people
hadn't seen on a movie screen up to that
point and then the battle of the
pelennor fields up that quotient even
higher not to mention had a lot of
emotional weight behind it because we
were so invested in these characters by
that point
by contrast the participants in the
battle of the five armies are largely
characters that we've seen very little
of have only seen sporadically
in fact just barely got introduced
thrown oakenshield's company of dwarves
and Bilbo Baggins Muhammad himself do
not actually take place in the battle
proper well the very ends the dwarves
kind of join in while Bilbo doesn't
really fight anybody at all so all the
participants in the actual titular
battle we've got almost no investment to
give a damn I mean there's the spectacle
of it but the spectacle is not any
better than we've gotten from any of the
other films and this franchise that said
I thought it was really cool to see an
army of dwarves fight because it's about
the one thing that was new because we've
seen orcs fight we've seen humans fight
we've seen elves fight though not quite
on this scale but we've never seen
dwarves aside from Gimli fight so to see
on an organized army of dwarves to see
the way that they fight that actually
was kind of thrilling and that made me
smile cuz it was something new it was
something I hadn't expected to see and
sort of going hidden him with that Billy
Connolly playing Dane does very well the
character is very thinly fleshed out but
Billy Connolly brings his Billy Connolly
nough switch I will always be happy to
see in any movie so yeah those were kind
of the good points the rest of it I was
either unaffected or irritated in fact a
lot always I felt like I was being given
the middle finger for my issues with the
series up to this point why was the last
20 minutes or so it was the desolation
of smaug chopped off and stuck at the
front end of this movie even though it
has almost nothing to do with the
proceedings of this film aside from just
a bit of backstory because few why are
we forced to spend more time than ever
with the CGI orcs who look terrible
compared to the practical effects makeup
used create orcs in the original Lord of
the Rings trilogy because you why was a
film shot on location of one of the
great unspoiled parts of the world
features some of the worst green-screen
I've seen in the last decade why is the
second in command or killed by Legolas
as opposed to tauriel who has a much
more emotionally charged and committed
reason to actually fight him and why
above all else is a battle that takes a
single chapter in the book and is
mentioned only after the fact because it
does not involve the titular character
of the story make the entire spine of
this film because you
this point I just feel used I feel like
they knew they were gonna get my money
and they just had to put a nice big
glossy presentation and go here give us
your money and it did you know when I
gave my thoughts on the final trailer
for this I jokingly called this the saga
of Thorin Oakenshield in a lot of ways
it is but I actually came in trying to
view this film possibly from that
perspective like okay how does this work
as a story about Thorin he's obviously
taking up a hell of a lot more
screentime and Peter Jackson seems to be
much more interested in him than he is
in Bilbo so how does it hold up as that
it doesn't because rather than making
Thorin a consistent character they've
had him yo-yo from seeing the scene in
accordance with what any given scene
wants in terms of how stubborn he is how
much he cares about Bilbo and how sort
of crazed for the treasure he is it
completely varies from scene to scene
especially if you look over the course
of the entire three films and I
understand certain interpretations of
what happens in the book there is
precedent for the notion that he gets
his hands on the gold and there is a
certain kind of madness involved in that
that just makes him unreasonable but you
know what else is a viable
interpretation if you read the book the
guy's just really stubborn and pigheaded
and I feel like the movie really copped
out and took the easy route with this
basically substituting the doors
treasure and the Arkenstone for the One
Ring and having it have that kind of
influence on him that the ring had on
various characters in The Lord of the
Rings trilogy I think that was the easy
way to go and if they're taking three
films they could have developed a really
legitimate art for Thorin and have it be
rooted in his stubbornness in his pride
and really ground these as faults and
flaws in the character rather than just
having it be a susceptibility to this
other influence and sort of make him
into this weird cross of Boromir and
Aragorn and while it's not explicit in
the original book that Thorin sort of
loses his mind and goes a little over
the top when he gets a hold of the gold
there is sort of that going on with his
character his behavior does alter
somewhat but they take it to an extreme
in this case because in the book Thorin
does lead the doors out onto the fields
for the Battle of the five armies in
this case Thorin holds himself up in the
mountain and lets his cousin who just
showed up do all the fighting for him
and he's content to sit back
and let his kin die so they took the
corrupting influence of gold and just
took it too far and then just had his
Redemption be basically he sort of comes
to senses and goes ah now I'm good and
it doesn't feel earned it doesn't work
it feels cheesy it just feels like they
hit the point in the story where they
needed him to be heroic again so they
made him heroic again I mean in the book
the point of the Battle of five armies
is basically to give Thorin Redemption
and he needs Redemption because he's so
stubborn so pigheaded so set in his ways
is so prideful the only way he was going
to see the error of what he had done and
his way of looking at the world was on
his deathbed so basically the Battle of
the five armies in the book exists just
as a way to kill Thorin so that he can
have that moment on his deathbed and say
to Bilbo if more of us valued food and
cheer above hoards of gold it would be a
merrier world the only way he was going
to come to that realization is when he
was dying that's what the Battle of the
five armies is only one chapter in the
book because the event itself doesn't
matter what it matters is that it
mortally was this character so it can
give him his final Redemption and in
this case because they have Thorin
basically sort of come to his senses and
rally and decide to take on the evil on
his own the redemption at the end
doesn't really feel right it feels more
like a half-hearted apology to Bilbo for
being a jerk and I suppose the last
thing to talk about the ending just
feels really really rushed and actually
even more so than initially struck me
because I had a friend who hasn't read
the books and isn't excessively familiar
with the source of material say hey do
they even address what happened with the
Arkenstone in the book they do it's
buried with Thorin but this thing that
they made such a big deal of in the
movie once they've hit the end and it's
time to send Bilbo back and just wrap
the movie up they don't even bother with
it why are they not even gonna wrap up
this thing that they made a bigger deal
than it even deserve to have because you
so there you go I don't really think it
works I don't think it really works as a
film unto itself I don't think it works
particularly as a trilogy focusing on
Thorin and I really don't think it works
as an adaptation of the book The Hobbit
I know some people have enjoyed these in
your mileage may vary
but I must have a hard time seeing how
even people who mainly know these
characters in this world through the
Lord of the Rings movies aren't looking
at this going this is not nearly as good
but at least it's over and I can stop
being pissed off about this so allow me
to ask you this what was your least
favorite film out of the six a
live-action middle-earth set films but
whatever one it is for you drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it and until next time this
council is adjourned